je vous propose une interview doublage
je vais vous poser une question à vous
Adèle mais je vais demander à Vincent de
répondre et vous je vais vous demander
de faire de lipsyke
c'est comment de travailler avec Vincent
c'était super de travailler avec Vincent
parce que c'est vraiment quelqu'un de
déjà très intelligent très drôle et
d'une finesse extrême enfin j'avais
rarement rencontré quelqu'un d'aussi fin
dans ma vie et donc c'était vraiment un
plaisir absolu de travailler avec lui il
est génial c'est peut-être même la
meilleure personne avec qui j'ai
travaillé de toute ma vie
ok à moi travailler avec Adèle c'est
voilà c'est
ça
comment vous avez réussi à bosser à
construire ces personnages si vous étiez
pas ensemble dans la cabine
je réponds normalement
arrêtez ça
vous êtes gênant d'accord j'aime bien
que le gros on nous demande d'arrêter le
concept au bout d'un moment ça